second quarter gdp data will be coming
out on thursday and pretty much every
serious economic analyst is predicting
that we will be heading into a recession
every serious economic analyst with the
exception of the economists who work for
joe biden according to the director of
president biden's national economic
council not only are we not in a
recession
we don't even understand what a
recession is
two quarters of negative growth in a row
that's a recession
right and certainly the in terms of the
technical definition it's not a
recession the technical definition
considers a much broader spectrum of
data points but in practical terms what
matters to the american people is
whether they have a little economic
breathing room they have more job
opportunities their wages are going up
that has been joe biden's focus since
coming into office he has had a view of
the economy that we need to look to
build from the bottom up in middle out
and what that means is that typical
working-class people in this country
have had trouble affording things for
years he is focused on building a strong
durable economic recovery here we have
real global challenges here in the short
term we've got to navigate our way
through them but we have to do so
without giving up all our economic gains
that's going to be our focus and i think
that we need to train that focus on that
rather than on sort of technical debates
about backward-looking data so the
consumer confidence numbers are are
going to come out as well and consumer
confidence has been
fairly
dismal those numbers have just been flat
out bad
i love that line at the end there oh
yeah okay man but you know it's all
pretty dismal and bad right even the cnn
guy has to admit that even the cnn guy
can't lie about it but the white house
economist is insisting that two quarters
down in gdp
is not
technically a recession so i thought
okay
this is a debate over the definition of
a word
so let's just look it up in the
dictionary and see what the definition
is pulled up my my little google i typed
in recession definition here's what i
got
top result featured on google from the
oxford dictionaries quote recession
a period of temporary economic decline
during which trade and industrial
activity are reduced generally
identified by a fall in gdp
in two successive quarters
that that is literally the definition of
a recession the national economic
council guy just
straight up lied about what a recession
is because if we don't call it a
recession we're not in a recession we're
just going to change all the words and
that's somehow going to change reality
that's the left-wing playbook
even the white house press secretary
queen john pierre was not that shameless
was not that brazen when corrine
jean-pierre was asked about the
recession
she just refused to answer
and what is exactly the white house's
definition of a recession again we don't
we don't def i'm not going to define it
from here i'm just going to leave it to
the nber as as we have stated how they
define uh recent recessions
i'm just saying that we're just not
going to define it we use the indicators
that the nber uh the national bureau of
economic research has used we've
mentioned that a few times
we're not going to define it yeah you're
not going to define it because by the
definition of a recession we are in one
and you don't want to admit that
you know i can't help but notice that
when things are going well the white
house doesn't have any problem defining
basic economic terms this white house
has not had very much good news but on
the few occasions they have for instance
they let people go back to work it was
kind of artificial but people weren't
allowed to go to work then the white
house lets people go back to work
obviously this is going to cause an
uptick in the economic numbers
well the white house sure knew what the
terms were then they used terms like
growth they used terms like job creation
they knew all those terms then but now
that we're headed into a recession that
we're in a recession all of a sudden i
don't know who's to say
what's recession man what do words mean
man what if the color i see is blue you
see is green you know what i'm saying
man
not to be outdone the treasury secretary
janet yellen achieved the finest
orwellian wordsmithing of all
janet yellen explained
that we're not well we're in something
we're not but it's not a it's not a
recession
it's more of a
transition
this is not an economy that's in
recession
but we're in a period of transition in
which growth is slowing and that's
necessary and appropriate
necessary and appropriate you see it's a
good thing it's a good thing that you
can't afford food and gas it's a it's a
good thing that the economy is declining
now it's not it's not a slowing of
growth by the way which is what she said
we're talking about
an actual economic decline the numbers
are are not going up but slowly they're
going down so what she said also is not
true
it's not a recession it's a transition
it's a transit we're transiting the kids
we're transiting the bathrooms
and now we're transing the economy and
the results of that are exactly as
destructive as you might expect i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is yet again from cool
papa j magic this is amazing i don't see
the names of people when i pick the
comments i just pick the comment i i
must have picked cool papa j magic a
hundred times on this show so far that
guy very sharp guy he writes did you
guys notice that they are starting to
use the term young people instead of
children that is on purpose and will
lead to levels of abuse we still have
yet to see really good point i actually
had not noticed that
and i usually try to pay very close
attention to the left's manipulation of
words wrote a book on it called
speechless i'm very interested in that
but it's so subtle sometimes even i miss
it even when i'm looking out for it that
shift from children or toddlers or
babies to young people is intended to
blur the line
between adults and children as they're
pushing all this grooming creepy sex
stuff on the kids
it's amazing when we're talking about
babies those aren't people those aren't
when because babies are inconvenient for
the left but then when we're talking
about really tiny little kids who
obviously can't make their own sexual
decisions all of a sudden it's young
people well young they're going to be
calling them young adults early trans 25
year olds that's what they're going to
be calling them things are going really
haywire when you want to protect what's
yours going into this crazy climate
you've got to go check out alto ira
right now go to
michael you may already be investing in
cryptocurrency but did you know that you
can trade bitcoin ethereum and over 80
other cryptocurrencies in a tax
advantaged ira with alto crypto ira you
can avoid or defer the taxes when
trading crypto like bitcoin
all those other coins that you like alto
offers alternative investment
opportunities such as private companies
crypto funds real estate venture capital
and more ulta crypto ira in particular
is a great way to start investing and
trading in crypto with a tax advantage
retirement account makes investing in
crypto super duper easy you create an
account in just a few minutes you invest
with as little as 10 bucks even we can
afford that even in this economy no set
up charges through alto's integration
with coinbase you get secure trading 24
7 alto offers industry-leading security
the advanced encryption standard for
wallets and private keys and alternative
investment opportunities through some of
the world's most recognized platforms
and fund partners open an ulta crypto
ira today with as little as 10 bucks go
to altoira dot com slash michael that's
a ltoira.com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today alto ira.com
michael
just transing
just transing the kids transiting
the economy we're transiting everything
the democrat premise here
is
what you say
will entirely determine reality
and this is why the all the transgender
stuff actually matters here
the premise is
if you say that a recession is not a
recession
then it's not a recession
the power the power of our speech is
such that we can totally change reality
if you say that a baby is not a baby
it's not a baby
when when we all talk about the royal
baby you know prince william and his
wife his wife is pregnant they're about
to have the royal baby we all talk about
the royal baby we don't talk about the
royal fetus or the royal embryo or the
royal zygote or whatever because that
baby is wanted and so we talk about him
honestly like he's a baby but when we
talk about some woman who maybe doesn't
want a baby we say oh it's not a baby
it's not a baby unless you want it
whatever we say that's what determines
it
you you had a little boy but maybe some
perverted parent wanted a little girl
actually
and so they pushed the child into the
transgender ideology
well okay you can have a little girl
just call him a little girl put him in a
dress he's a little girl
that's easy
no we don't we don't need to worry about
reality we can just change it with our
language and that's what parents are
doing there's a tick tock that just went
viral i think i've got a block tick tock
on my except that it's so funny in a
really dark
sad way tick tock is very funny there
are some parents who just went viral
because they held a gender reveal party
not a gender reveal party for their baby
a gender reveal party for their toddler
because the toddler apparently is
transgender
what are you waiting
we practice acceptance is what they
write and they say it's a gender reveal
and they've got the little transgender
flag and then
the the poor little kid is excited
because because the parents are throwing
all sorts of fun little glitter and
things in the air and so the kid is
excited not realizing the these parents
are
sexually abusing the child
why are the parents doing this i don't
know because they're sickos maybe it's
satire maybe i don't know that it's
satire the line between satire and
reality is pretty blurred these days i
don't think it's satire
it'd be kind of weird to subject your
kid to this in public
if it were just a big joke or you were
making just some political point about
how transgenderism's crazy so i think
they're doing it for real and they're
doing it for clout that's one of the
reasons that parents are pushed to to
trans their kids is because that's the
new hip cool thing to do and that makes
you really cutting edge and avant-garde
and liberal and socially acceptable so
that's one of the
uh social
uh
impetuses for for doing this
they are getting clout they are going to
get lots of likes and they are going to
go viral and it's going to give that
mother all of the attention she's always
craved and so that will happen
but why is the culture
giving the parents this cloud it doesn't
just end with the culture okay i know
we're so fond of saying politics is
downstream of culture and we've said it
on the right for 10 or 15 years but
there's more to the story than that
culture is also downstream of politics
so one of the reasons why this is being
encouraged and promoted is because we
now have laws in place that encourage
people to trans their kids
we have laws and regulations in place
where if you don't trans your kids you
can be in trouble you can be accused of
child abuse or neglect we have laws and
rules in place where teachers and other
other ministers of the state can trans
your kid without your knowledge we now
have laws in place
going all the way up to the civil rights
act that have legal protections for
gender identity there are enshrining in
law this idea of transgenderism
so the law the politics not just the
culture but the politics and the
government and the law are creating
incentives for transgenderism and are
punishing people for upholding the
traditional and correct view of sex and
gender and so that's that's something
else that is pushing the culture in this
direction is it any wonder that in this
moment
you are seeing a major political
reaction from the right and the name of
that political reaction the name that
the left is putting on that political
reaction the the big political fight
that we're heading into even if we're
not quite in it yet is over
christian nationalism
now when you want to protect the assets
that are yours heading into tempestuous
moments you gotta go check out birch
gold right now text knolls to
989898 the latest inflation numbers are
in they're not good we are now at a
40-year high it's 9.1 percent thanks to
this genius administration our nation's
authorities are openly admitting at this
point that they completely missed the
flashing red lights of inflation and
this administration's failed economic
policy quote
i was wrong about the path inflation
would take that's not a quote from me i
was not wrong i was right but the
treasury secretary janet yellen was
wrong and she admitted it quote there
have been unanticipated and large shocks
to the economy that have boosted energy
and food prices and supply bottlenecks
that have affected our economy badly
that at the time i didn't fully
understand we fully understood it
or largely understood it this
administration did not okay you can't
trust these so-called authorities when
it comes to economic policy that's why
you should invest at least some of your
money in gold and silver with birch gold
group you can diversify your 401k or ira
into physical gold it's not too late
best time to do it is yesterday second
best time to do it is today text knowles
k w l e s 2 9 8 9 8 9 8 get a free info
kit on diversifying and protecting your
savings with precious metals birch gold
group has an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless five
star reviews thousands of satisfied
customers text knolls to 989898 and get
real advice from birch gold today nols
canon wlas text it to 989 898 claim your
free no obligation info kit on
protecting your savings with gold
against the backdrop of gender reveal
parties for your two-year-old when you
pretend the little girl's a little boy
or vice versa
against the backdrop of drag queen story
hour for toddlers
against the backdrop of all of this
you have
right wingers coming out
that those kooky crazy awful radical
right wingers marjorie taylor green
oh the worst most right-wing awful
person of them all and she's saying oh
gosh i don't even can i even utter this
phrase it's the scariest phrase in
politics according to cnn
marjorie taylor green is saying
whatever that stuff is i'm not that in
fact i'm a christian nationalist
i believe in accountability and i
believe in not just saying something but
following through on it and i believe
that republicans need to prove to the
american people that we are the party of
american nationalism
and christian nationalism i'm a
christian i have no problem saying i'm a
christian nationalist and i think that's
an identity that we need to embrace
because those are the policies that
serve every single american regardless
of how they vote they could be a
democrat and a progressive but christian
nationalist or american nationalist
america first policies
still
serve those people because they're the
right policies for everyone a christian
nationalist and and it's coming from
marjory taylor green who is this
conservative member of congress that the
libs have really focused on they really
really hate this woman and then they try
to make this into a scare term christian
nationalism cnn has a long article gosh
this article never ends called an
imposter christianity is threatening
american democracy i want to pause right
there because they explain what they
mean by christian nationalism but before
we get to it
i love they use this phrase it's an
imposter christianity it's not the real
christianity you ever notice the libs do
this whenever you say things that are
really basic aspects of the christian
religion and a christian culture they'll
say you're not really a christian you're
not a real christian jesus you know he
was a hippie socialist i love they
always say jesus was too if you believe
in christianity you don't say jesus was
you say jesus is because he rises from
the dead and he lives
in heaven and he's our king and our
savior lives but they always say you
know jesus he was a radical left wing
this that and they name all these things
because these people have never cracked
open a bible in their lives
and they say and he you're a terrible
christian you're not a real true good
christian
and also christianity's really stupid
and dumb and you shouldn't believe it
you're not you're a fake imposter
hypocritical artificial christian but
also christianity is really totally
insane why would anybody believe that
they they say both of these at the same
time
out of both sides of their mouths that's
a minor digression they say an imposter
christianity is threatening american
democracy this is christian nationalism
what does the cnn article say christian
nationalism is
what's it all about first part
erasing the line
separating piety from politics is a key
characteristic of white christian
nationalism okay that part's true you're
right christian i don't know white
christian nation what does that even
mean christianity there is neither jew
nor greek nor slave nor free but all are
one in christ jesus but okay whatever
they don't know what they're talking
obviously they don't know what they're
talking about let's get to that point
they say erasing the line between piety
and politics they're saying it's making
politics more
explicitly religious yeah that's true
that's true
but we're not the only ones doing that
do you
you think that the left has a firm line
between piety and politics all the left
ever does is virtue signal the only
difference is that they're what they
call virtue is actually vice
you think that the left isn't pious you
don't what are you talking about you
think the left doesn't have religious
views that they foist on all of us
they're pretending that human beings can
actually secretly be the opposite sex
they're they're making a metaphysical
claim that the soul is totally different
from the body
and they're forcing you to to engage in
a sacramental sort of ritual to
transgender your little toddlers
you don't think that's pious you don't
think a pride parade is a kind of
weirdo version of piety of course it is
it's a religious ritual it's just not
for christianity or islam or judaism or
any thing that we would call a
traditional religion it's it's just for
leftism
so okay yeah you're right
christian christian nationalists want to
separate
or want want to bring together a little
more
piety and politics a little closer
together sure the libs are already doing
that they've been doing it forever next
line one of the most popular beliefs
among white christian nationalists is
that the u.s was founded as a christian
nation uh that's true that is a popular
belief because it's
inarguably correct
yeah
have you ever heard of the mayflower
have you ever heard of the pilgrims have
you ever heard of the the people who
settled our country
what do you think that would you call
them
christian
i i would call them so zealously
christian so
hyper focused on their particular brand
of protestant christianity that they
fled england another protestant
christian country they fled it because
they thought they were too heathen and
then they were in the netherlands they
were in leiden and then they fled there
because they felt that was too
sort of secular and fun and then they
came to america
to the hinterlands where half of them
died in the first winter just so they
could practice their extremely rigid
form of christianity
i think they were christian
the
vast majority virtually everyone in
america at the time of the founding so
fast forward now a century and a half
here in 1776
virtually everybody in america
at the time of the founding including
the founding fathers who were largely
christians some of them had sort of
heterodox beliefs and some of them
verged on deism but they were
overwhelmingly christian they those
people believed in
some version of christianity the only
line that these people can ever point to
when they say america's not a christian
nation is one line from the treaty of
tripoli which says america is not
founded as a christian nation and they
say john adams said that john adams
didn't say that the treaty of tripoli is
a diplomatic document to assuage muslim
pirates who were imprisoning and
stealing and kidnapping american sailors
that's all it was about if you look at
john adams's diaries if you look at the
founding documents of the united states
if you look at the writings of virtually
all of the founding fathers they
describe america in overtly christian
terms that's what john adams says he
says the morality for america is the
christian morality when when at the
continental congress the the
early proto-americans are invoking god
and the blessings of god explicitly what
do you think that is who do you think
they're talking to do you think they're
talking to allah do you think they're
talking to
shiva no they're talking to a christian
god
a broadly christian understanding of who
god is when george washington issues a
thanksgiving proclamation who's he
giving thanks to
he's not giving thanks to some
lib social construction man he's giving
thanks to god so it's just that's in
in contestable that america is founded
as a christian nation
i believe the third one a belief in a
warrior christ the idea that christ
is
calls on us to do things that we have a
role in the world that
the cnn says this is totally out of
keeping with christianity because they
haven't read their bible but of course
what does christ say he says a great
many things in the gospels one of them
is i come not to bring
peace but a sword
one of them is to establish a church and
go out and preach to all of the nations
the way that the church understands
itself is in three states traditionally
this is how the church understands
itself as the church
penitent and the church triumphant and
the church militant
you might have heard that phrase before
church militant that means the church on
earth the church penitent is the church
in purgatory the church triumphant is
the church in heaven and the church
militant is the church here on earth
the entire bible is infused with
language about spiritual warfare
spiritual combat that is a combat
and then finally they say christian
nationalism is a threat to democracy and
there's that's my favorite line this is
my favorite line of all because
but the libs do this all the time
whenever people the people vote against
their preferences they say it's a threat
to democracy
which is of course nonsensical
if most people
are voting for a thing that can't be a
threat to democracy they say when peop
when people vote for trump oh no it's a
threat to democracy the people elected
trump you can't have that it's not just
in america in hungary when the people
elect victor orban who's a right-wing
leader there this is a threat to
democracy the people have voted for this
thing and now they've got that form of
government what a threat to democracy
bolsonaro down in brazil another
right-wing leader this is oh no the
people elected a right-winger this is a
threat to democracy no it's a threat to
liberalism that's what they mean when
they say democracy they mean liberalism
or progressivism or leftism all of which
are increasingly unpopular and so the
libs are really upset about this and
they are lying and they're or they're
just ignorant and they're pretending
that that threatens democracy the reason
christian nationalism is the term here
the scare term why it's why they're
going after marjory taylor green that's
why they're going after all these
conservatives and specifically christian
nationalism is because it's the opposite
of leftist globalism
nationalism is the opposite of globalism
christianity is the opposite of leftism
i'm not even making this as a cheap shot
the term the left comes from the french
revolution when people who sat on the
left of the national assembly opposed
the church those the people who opposed
the church sat on the left the people
who defended the church and the state
they sat on the right so they're just
opposites the
they're saying when they call you a
christian nationalist they're saying
you oppose our leftist globalism and on
that charge my friends
guilty i played happily i plead
guilty now someday some day when we're
thinking about eschatological
language heroin or thinking about the
end of the world you are going to die
that's why you need a will that's why
you gotta go check out epic will 100 of
people who skydive will die 100 of
people who get in a car will die 100 of
people who take a breath of oxygen will
die at some point okay no one here gets
out alive that's why you've got to take
care of your affairs it's why you need a
will a will is not about you or it's not
just about you it's not mostly about you
it's about your loved ones it's about
your stuff it's about who's going to
make difficult decisions if something
happens to you do yourself a favor do
your family a favor make those decisions
now so that they don't have to face them
later without you go to epicwell.com use
promo code knowles canadawles save 10 on
epic will's complete will package epic
will can set you up with a will in as
little as five minutes which is
unbelievable it's incredibly easy well
worth the 119 bucks that it takes to
secure your family's future fast without
a will you may as well wrap up all your
money and your assets and your kids and
hand them over to bad guys who don't
like you very much
no matter where you're at in life you
need to have a will go to epicwill.com
use my code
nolescannerwles today
this is the moment in the show
where in the years past i would have
read you an ad for harry's razors
remember harry's i would have said hey
you millions of listeners out there i
love harry's go out and buy a harry's
right but i'm
i'm not gonna do that because i don't
love harry's i hate harry's
if if you don't know the story you
certainly should harry is used to
advertise on our shows until someone
around here i'm not uh i don't know was
it oh yes it was me said that boys or
boys and girls or girls and this was too
much for harry's
so harry's pulled their ads due to
values misalignment quote-unquote
well we're not going to promote products
that hate your values and so we did the
only thing that makes sense we launched
our own razor company jeremy's razors
every jeremy's razor's kit comes with a
premium razor two sets of blades shaving
cream and aftershave bomb
it's a beautiful thing to behold over 70
000 kits have shipped already not been
ordered have shipped
so instead of telling you that i a big
fan of harry's love here is i'm here to
tell you about the thousands of ex
harry's users
who have thrown their razors in the
trash and switched to jeremy's do not go
to harrys.com go to
ihateharrys.com get your jeremy's razors
founders kit it's time to stop giving
your money to what corporations that
hate you give it to jeremy instead we'll
be right back with a lot more
left-wing activists in illinois
are very upset
that a public library is considering
taking gay porn out of the young
people's section of the taxpayer-funded
public library
the libs are very upset how dare you
consider taking gay porn out of the
libraries
here's what they say in their own words
i am not upset by these books and i
don't understand how people
how they would be
so i looked it up online to see what
people could be complaining about
because i have read the books
and some people claim they're porno
so they're either mad because it's porn
or because it's lgbtqia porn and this
upsets you you're really against porn or
you're homophobic are you going to try
to ban straight romance novels too and
have no straight porn in the library if
you read the book
and i have
three times
i
strongly encourage people who are
experiencing conflict
to please give genderqueer a try it is
not
pornography
i have seen
a great many things in my life as a
librarian at various book selling stalls
this
is not
an erotic
adventure
in any way shape or form it is a true
expression of what this person
felt to be their life
it might be a true expression of what
this pervert author thought to be
his or her life sure but it is
pornography it is and if you're watching
that clip instead of listening to this
on your podcast app or on the radio you
would have seen just some of the images
from the book which are pornography and
they're not just pornography they're gay
pornography and they're not just gay
pornography they're gay pornography
aimed at children
and for all of those reasons in
increasing severity
increasing urgency you've got to get
this out of the library there is no free
speech protection for pornography there
never was in the united states there's
actually still isn't according to the
law but those laws have not been
enforced in recent decades but it's
preposterous
this there is uh
no
no no serious person who has ever argued
for free speech and the free exchange of
ideas no serious person philosopher
statesman has ever suggested that some
work of philosophy has the same
some work of pornography has the same
kind of protection as some work of
philosophy no one would seriously argue
that that was not reflected in our law
in fact that still is not reflected in
our law
it is a reminder though
when you heard that woman say she goes
what oh my gosh if you oppose this book
look it's not pornography it's totally
not gay porn but okay let's you know
let's just admit for a second that it is
that means that you're really against
pornography
or you're homophobic
now what i mean homophobia
would would be an irrational fear of
homosexuals and that's not what they're
talking about that's not what this woman
is accusing anyone of
she's accusing people of having moral
approbrium
feeling a kind of moral appropriation
for
certain types of sex acts
which everyone feels everyone looks at
at least some kinds of sex acts and says
those are wrong at the very least for
instance we would all say
pedophilia is wrong well actually the
libs these days i'm not so sure some of
the libs are trying to normalize
pedophilia they're trying to change the
term to be minor attracted person or
bestiality i think we should all be able
to agree virtually everyone should be
able to agree bestiality is wrong it's a
sex act but we can look on it with moral
or program and that's not a kind of
phobia okay and so traditionally people
have viewed a much broader range of
sexual acts with moral appropriate said
no you really shouldn't do those things
not just same-sex acts but polygamous
sex acts certain sex acts between a man
and a woman this is kind of
christianity islam judaism some forms of
paganism traditional society 101 says
yeah obviously sex is a very important
thing in human life it has a lot to do
not just with our private lives but with
all of society because the family the
marriage is the fundamental political
unit and so we're going to look at
certain sexual acts with a kind of
appropriate
these people are saying no that's
totally crazy that's totally
uh phobic and irrational and why even
forget about the same-sex stuff for a
second why would you even be against
porn i don't know let me put the
question back on you why has every
society ever
had some prohibitions on porn
why is that were they all just crazy
including our own society right now why
why
even presently does every single society
on earth have some kinds of prohibitions
on at least some kinds of porn
they're all just nuts they're all just
no they're all just closed-minded no
that because we know that sex is a very
powerful motivator and we know that our
lusts can be very very powerful things
and they can be really dangerous to
ourselves and to society and we've got
to reign it in and especially if we want
to have self-government we want to
control ourselves we need to be able to
tamp down those really really base
appetites and cultivate our higher
rational will that's why
and that's especially true for kids
maybe older people
can reign it in a little bit more
maybe just like just like older people
maybe can
drink
or even do some drugs again i'm not
incur i don't think we should legalize
drugs i don't think we should
further legalize porn or anything like
that but certainly we would say an adult
is a little more capable of dealing with
that than a little kid that's why we
don't like kids drink that's why we
don't like kids do a whole lot of things
and certainly we shouldn't let kids look
at porn in the libraries
okay
and these people look at you and they
say you're crazy
they look at you and they say your moral
system is wrong
my moral system is right
your christian nationalism
is awful
my leftist globalism is good
so what are those they're both making
moral claims what are the moral claims
christian nationalism
no porn for little kids in the library
leftist globalism
trans the kids trans the two-year-olds
take the toddlers to drag queen story
hour
you're gonna have to live under one of
those moral systems
which one do you want one of those
political orders which one do you want
to live under
christian nationalism sure if those are
the choices
those look like the choices right now
christian nationalism or leftist
globalism
any sane person
of any religious background of any
sexual desires of any race of any
geography any sane person
would prefer to live under
christian nationalism than leftist
globalism and every single person will
do better
under christian nationalism than they
would under leftist globalism
this is why it's not just the fringe
radical marjorie taylor greens they
really hate marge retailer green it's
not but it's not just her it's not just
some members of the house of
representatives even the most mainstream
kinds of
executive governor national level
conservatives ron desantis it's really
hard to call ron desantis a fringe crazy
figure ron desantis is using the exact
kind of language this is from a couple
of months ago ron desantis was at a
rally he called on people to put on the
armor of god
gird your loins for battle gerds are
alive
you put on the full armor of god
you take a stand against the left
schemes yeah you're gonna face flaming
arrows but if you stand for truth you
and we will prevail
so this is just explicitly biblical
language christian language and it's
totally right
which
let's say you had two two politicians
giving speeches they they get into a
time machine
they go back to 1776
and they start talking
and one of the politicians is ron
desantis and the other one is
aoc let's say
okay the libs right now are saying that
christian nationalism is uh is
completely out of touch with the
american tradition it's a total
perversion of america the founders
wouldn't have liked this and nobody this
was totally on
totally unnatural to the american way of
life okay so you got ron desantis and
aoc and they both get in their time
machine they go back to 1776 ron
desantis gives that exact speech
verbatim and then aoc talks about how
transgender rights are human rights and
we need abortion on demand without
apology and no human being is illegal
which is why we need to open up all the
borders
which do you think the crowd would
prefer which do you think the crowd
would say this makes more sense oh yeah
i've heard this before
what ron de santa said would sound like
pretty much just anybody in their
society except his accent wouldn't be
quite as silly and he wouldn't be
wearing a powdered wig but otherwise
people would that guy would fit in okay
at the constitutional
congress
the the
continental congress rather or the
constitutional convention either one of
them they would fit in they'd say you
look a little swarthy you're a little on
the italian side but that's okay all
right you still vaguely fit in
aoc comes and she starts talking about
transiting the kids in abortion they say
who the hell is this lady what planet
did you come from lady
obviously
this one is in the american tradition no
question about it now speaking of men
who want to be president donald trump
is laying out his plans
for his second term donald trump
i would say all the smart money right
now is saying donald trump is going to
run for president so all this horse race
jockeying that people are talking about
ron desantis ted cruz nikki haley mike
pompeo mike pence they're all talking
about these horse races and i i really
like a lot of those people i think ron
desantis is a phenomenal candidate i
think he's the best governor certainly
in the country right now maybe the best
governor in america in my lifetime you
know i love senator cruz i do his show
with him i even like some of the other
people too who could be running
but none of that really matters actually
because if trump runs
he almost certainly will win the primary
because his numbers are so far up right
now
they're up 40 points and so you hear
people complain they say no but this
candidate would be so much better no i
don't like trump you know he's even some
people who hated trump in 2016. i always
kind of liked trump i had my
reservations about him during the
primaries in 2016. i voted for him in
the general i voted for him in 2020. i'm
not saying he's perfect there are some
things he did that really drove me crazy
i hated that first step act you know so
i'm not i don't like worship the guy as
a demigod but he was by far the most
conservative president of my lifetime
and i like him and i'm noticing now a
lot of people who didn't like him in
2016. they're kind of turning up maybe
they liked him in 2020 maybe they didn't
but they're they kind of don't like him
again now and they're pulling for other
candidates and i get it that's it's all
a fair debate but guys it's how about
reality if trump says he's running he is
99 out of 100 going to win the primary
so now the question is if he is going to
run what is he going to do what is his
campaign going to be and right now what
trump is campaigning on is not just
immigration it's not build the wall
wish he could have built more of the
wall but it's not just build the wall
it's not pro-life he he is the most
pro-life president ever he got roe v
wade overruled it's not
the economy that's kind of a given it
the issue that he is running on right
now
is firing 50 000 government bureaucrats
in the deep state
here are just some of the other things
we must do with republicans
back in charge we must pass
critical reforms making every executive
branch employee
fireable
by the president the deep state must
and will
be brought to heal
the deep state
must and will be brought to heal this is
what the libs are freaking out over to
you can you can tell
generally which republican policies
matter by which ones the libs are most
freaked out over and this one they're
really scared they call this a coup
they call this a new a radical plan for
trump's second term i mentioned it at
the very end of the show yesterday but
what trump is talking about here
is something called schedule f and it's
a bureaucratic measure to change the way
that employees
work in the federal government and to
change what kind of employment
protections they have generally speaking
when when any president comes into
office they switch over something like 4
000 members of the federal bureaucracy
and it's usually those top level guys
the top level guys and the people just
below the top level guys federal
bureaucracy is something like 2 million
people so you change out 4 000 people
that's nothing
that's you haven't changed anything and
so the elected guys come in they put
their guys at the very tippy top of the
bureaucracy
but all those career people they know
they're going to be there a lot longer
than the elected people or the appointed
people and so they don't really have to
do anything when democrats get elected
this doesn't matter because the federal
bureaucracy is
overwhelmingly left-wing so the
machinery of government generally works
when it's the libs in charge
but when the republicans come in
especially if we're talking about
conservative republicans
not just the squishy people but the ones
who actually want to change something
nothing's going to get done
because the federal bureaucracy is going
to be sitting there they're going to say
oh that guy at the top told me to do
something okay
i'm gonna drag my feet
gonna drag my feet for about four years
and oh you're going okay bye all right
back to normal
to do never mind and there's no
consequence because they have really
strong employment projections so what
trump is proposing is firing 50 000
members of the federal bureaucracy now
we're talking now we're making a start
here and the libs are saying this is a
threat to democracy can you imagine
can you imagine there is something
called the federal bureaucracy which is
completely unaccountable to the american
people the american people express their
desires through elections and the
federal bureaucracy says cool pound sand
we don't care
very anti-democratic
then trump comes in and he says i
propose that presidents should have more
power to fire these these bureaucrats
who are the ones actually making an
enforcing policy so that the way that
the government operates actually
reflects of the will of the people very
pro-democracy it's a big pro-democracy
reform what do the libs say they say
well this is this is a threat to
american democracy because they don't
mean american democracy they mean
liberalism leftism progressivism they
mean
their agenda
speaking of shrinking things
you you all know how bad inflation is
you you have seen the numbers we're
going to get more numbers on tuesday
which is going to be very unfortunate
not just you're going to get economic
numbers on thursday to show that we're
in a recession even though the biden
administration refuses to admit it
because they they changed the definition
of the words
then
you're going to you're going to get
inflation numbers you see inflation is
up 9.1
year over year this is a massive part of
inflation but i'm here to tell you folks
things are even worse than that
i don't worry i've got hope things can
get a lot worse they are getting a lot
worse
because while you've got the economic
collapse while you've got inflation
making everything more expensive you
also have something called shrink
inflation
and shrink flation is really subtle and
shrink-flation actually hides the way
the severity of inflation because while
prices are going up the products you're
buying are getting smaller this happened
to me over the weekend i was going to
buy cheese had a couple of friends over
we were making fondue
fun it's really fun you know it's like
we were right back in the 1970s i was
going to go out and buy the cheese to
make the fondue and i had to buy
24 ounces of cheese so i'm buying
different kinds of cheese and i pick up
a
little block of cheese and i see the
block of cheese
is 5.9 ounces of cheese
why
what executive
would make cheese 5.9 ounces per block
that is the most useless
denomination of cheese the amount of
cheese i there is not a single recipe on
earth that calls for 5.9 ounces of
cheese
might call for six ounces of cheese
more likely i don't know eight ounces of
cheese
5.9 why did they do that they're
shrinking the amount of cheese so that
you won't notice that even if the price
goes up a little bit you're not noticing
it's actually going up a lot more per
ounce of cheese and it's happening
everywhere not just in my fondue it's
happening throughout the economy honey
bunches of oats you know i love honey
that's one of my favorite cereals
the box of honey bunches of oats used to
be 14 and a half ounces it is now 12
ounces
that sounds like oh who cares what it's
two ounces two and a half ounces of
honey bunches of oats how many oats can
that be well that's a reduction
of 17
the daily mail is reporting all of these
numbers so you're getting 17 percent
fewer honey bunches of votes
and you're probably you're paying either
the same price or more likely you're
paying a little bit more for it
so effectively you're losing much more
of your oats angel soft toilet paper has
just reduced its size from 425 sheets
per roll to 320 you're not going to
notice that you're not counting the
sheets per roll in your angel soft
toilet tissue
but you are
getting
a lot a significantly reduced product
for the amount of money you're paying
bounty paper towels have cut their rolls
from 165 sheets to 147 sheets per roll
that happened late last year as we're
heading into all of this
you can't notice that why why would they
do that there's no argument from the
product standpoint to reduce it to 147
sheets they didn't discover 147 sheets
that's the ideal number of sheets per
bounty paper towel no they did it to
save money and to deceive you because
they got to try to cut corners somewhere
gatorade is down bottle used to be 32
ounces now it's 28 ounces folger's
coffee the canister used to be 51 ounces
now it's 43.5 ounces
the inflation is even worse
than it seems
speaking of consumption speaking of
things
getting worse there's a story that was
going all around the internet where is
it
here it is it's from the new york times
and a lot of conservatives were
freaking out over this
it's called a taste for cannibalism
and it was a cultural review of a spate
of recent stomach churning books tv
shows and films suggesting we've never
looked so delicious
to one another
the new york times article goes on and
on about all of these stories of
cannibalism
now
a lot of conservatives looked at this
and said oh my gosh this is crazy first
they try to make us eat bugs now they
try to make us eat each other this is
this is awful this is terrible
but here here's one paragraph that i
really wanted to focus in on because i
have an unpopular take on this i really
liked the article and i think they're
correct i think the new york times it
stopped clocked twice a day the new york
times is observing a cultural trend and
they're even correct in a kind of
left-wing critique they're making in the
article they're saying the cannibalism
movies and books it's not really about
wanting to eat other people there might
be a little bit of that there
but there might be you know listen we
we've got a lot of sexual perversion in
this country they've probably got a
little bit of that there but it's it's
more a comment on society and how we
relate to one another they say
more generally
ms summers thinks that the recent spate
of cannibalistic plots could also be
commentaries on capitalism
cannibalism is about consumption and
it's about churning up from the inside
in order to exist burnout is essentially
over consuming yourself your own energy
your own will to survive your sleep
schedule your eating schedule your your
body
this is kind of a stupid point but
there's a little kernel of truth there
some people have pointed out that the
cannibalism stuff is probably about
communism because under communism you
don't have any food
so you have to eat each other like like
someone who's plane crashes in the andes
you have to eat people but
i think they make a good point here on
capitalism and
you've got to remember i know
conservatives reflexively defend
capitalism
capitalism is a word that was
popularized by karl marx okay when we
talk about capitalism we're using kind
of marxist terminology actually i don't
consider myself a capitalist my ideology
is capitalism no i love private property
i love entrepreneurship i love hard work
i love i love all that stuff
i like producing more material goods to
help people
but i don't i don't like capital
capitalism is just a materialist
ideology like any other that says that
man is just made to consume and get a
lot of stuff and at the worst end of it
worship mammon and our fellow man we
don't view them as men made in the image
of god we just view them as cogs and a
machine to make more crap so i don't
like that side of it at all
i would consider my what would be a good
term i don't you might say christian
nationalist i don't know i consider
myself a christian an american a
conservative and so i i like
the fruits of private industry
but as a means to an end there is more
here as well and at the very worst side
of capitalism or really called
liberalism or whatever ism you want to
use we stop viewing human beings as
fellow men we start viewing them as just
things that can be useful to us to
produce more to work more for our sexual
pleasure for what for whatever purpose
we find ourselves we start to consume
one another
we start to view each other oh my gosh
the abortion regime i totally see
abortion here in this cannibal
culture
or where i'm a mother says i'm just
going to devour my own child because i i
want to serve my own ends of my career
or more money or more personal choice or
i get to go to brunch more frequently or
i get to go to the club or whatever
that that is a really bad thing and that
is maybe the word capitalism isn't the
right word here maybe we should just
call it modernity
maybe we should call it leftism leftist
globalism whatever all i know is
i whatever that culture is i don't like
it i don't want it i think the times is
observing something that's real i'm
observing it myself
and i don't like it we need an
alternative
and whatever you want to whatever you
want to call that alternative
people are calling it christian
nationalism i think that's as good a
term as any whatever that alternative is
that's what we have to defend we have to
stop accepting the premises of the left
we need to stop being engaged in this
fight
over the same very same premises of
leftist globalism and just following
them down down the road to perdition off
a cliff i'll keep mixing metaphors we
need to offer
not just democrat light i talked about
this yesterday not just democrat
policies from 10 years ago we need to
offer a clear alternative of a choice
not an echo i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show